sì sono ricorsa dal mio tour europeo ma
ci tenevo tantissimo essere qui oggi
perché sta lavorando al nuovo film sulla
crisi dell'unione europea negli occhi
dei cittadini è una delle idee di cui
voglio parlare oggi è come i nuovi
documentari hanno bisogno di voi hanno
bisogno di voi come produttori come
distributori non siete più un pubblico
eravate una volta un pubblico adesso
fate parte della rivoluzione nuovi
documentari quindi non potevo fare a
meno di venire a trovare i miei nuovi
produttori del mio prossimo film
e vi vorrei parlare di come nuovi
documentari possono riaccendere la luce
dell'informazione
all'inizio fu la luce una luce dei
fratelli lumière il cinema nasce
documentario queste sono le primissime
immagini del cinema il mondo scopre uno
dei mezzi di comunicazione più potenti
in assoluto e secondo me il cinema
quando hai documentario è il più
irresistibile ma idea che possa mai
esistere perché
secondo me perché replica in qualche
modo il modo in cui da piccoli noi
impariamo a conoscere il mondo noi
impariamo a conoscere la vita guardando
le persone che si muovono intorno a noi
ascoltando le loro storie e qual è la
forza del cinema documentario e quando
riesce riesce a coinvolgerci a un
livello che è molto più che sono
intellettuale razionale che riesce a
coinvolgere c con le emozioni riesce a
farci partecipi ci impedisce di girare
la testa dall'altra parte dire messo nel
film quando il cinema documentario e
grande riesce un capolavoro di
comunicazione di trasmissione di
informazione di sensazioni e di emozioni
eppure il cinema e documentario dopo un
inizio
strepitoso con russo ziga vertov e poi
in francia con il sine vérité di jean
rouge si addormenta diventa un genere
considerato un po polveroso didattico
noioso e questo sta cambiando invece
perché stiamo assistendo a una
rivoluzione secondo me importantissima
che ancora non è ben compreso e ben
capita come tutte le rivoluzioni della
comunicazione ci vuole tempo ed è un
momento di evoluzione confusa di
trasformazione però io
due anni fa ho fatto film che fondina
coma un film documentario realizzato
insieme all'ex direttore dell'economist
bill emmott ed è stato un film che
voleva in qualche modo tentare questa
esperienza di combinare
cinema arte poesia con giornalismo per
cercare di dare alle informazioni che
noi volevamo trasmettere un potere anche
di
il coinvolgimento del del cuore delle
emozioni voleva creare
è un po di shock e coinvolgere la gente
a fermarsi e riflettere
ebbene il film ha avuto una storia
abbastanza straordinaria al di là delle
nostre aspettative perché è diventato
virale
ha subito un contagio che sembra una
parola brutta in realtà è stata una cosa
meravigliosa un contagio di entusiasmo
che l'ha portato in più di 40 posti
proiezioni indipendenti organizzate
molto spesso da ragazzi da studenti e
molto spesso l'università e siamo venuti
anche qui a ca foscari per un bellissimo
dibattito eccola l'esperienza di ghelfi
nina co ma mi ha insegnato molto ma
soprattutto mi ha fatto capire come
quello che noi stavamo facendo
poteva essere l'inizio di qualcosa
l'inizio di un nuovo modo di realizzare
in formazione che aiuti ad analizzare la
complessità del mondo che ci circonda
costruendo un linguaggio che non fosse
né quello del giornalismo tradizionale
né quello del documentario classico un
po noioso ma un nuovo modo di comunicare
ed ecco questa è un po in sintesi la
rivoluzione che sta avvenendo e che
avviene un po dappertutto nel mondo
nelle università americana nel dove sono
sempre un pochino più avanti di noi
hanno già stabilito degli arti menti di
studi il mit massachusetts institute of
technology ha di recente fatto un
seminario seminario intitolato le arti
del documentario the new york
documentali appunto identificando che ci
sono delle espressioni artistiche
creative che stanno in moto grazie alla
confluenza di tecnologia social media è
un vero desiderio di
di informazione diversa
ma che cos'è il documentario
il documentario sfugge in realtà
qualsiasi codificazione in questo
momento questo è un bene perché c'è di
tutto sta succedendo di tutto e
ci sono diversi filoni harvard per
esempio stanno sperimentando sulla
confluenza di etnografia e filmaking e
tradizionale ma ci sono anche degli
studi su come il giornalismo possa
rinascere attraverso il documentario il
giornalismo tradizionale che è in crisi
lo sappiamo
i giornali non riescono più a svolgere
l'orgoglio di informazione ma il
documentario quindi diventa a pieno
diritto
un nuovo modo di guardare la realtà
completamente scardinato da qualsiasi
qualificazione che poteva esistere
prima quindi una rivoluzione è però la
rivoluzione che ha bisogno anche di
addetti nei tanti proseliti persone che
incominciano a parlarne per far sì che
questa scintilla che si è accesa non si
spenga perché purtroppo per molto il
documentario non è una cosa da
rivoluzione
uno pensa a una famiglia che guarda
piero angela
questa volta di casa addormentandosi non
vede le citazioni invece c'è bisogno di
diffondere questi nuovi documentari
perché rispondono a una domanda tale del
nostro tempo
e qui l'idea che voglio condividere con
voi già 30 anni fa
herbert simon uno dei primi studiosi di
intelligenza artificiale e di psicologia
prevedeva che l'accelerazione della
tecnologia informatica e della capacità
di trasmettere dati e magari azzinari
dati avrebbe creato a breve un mutamento
quasi neuronale perché perché il
bombardamento continuo di informazione
la quantità di informazione che si
poteva creare avrebbe creato una tale
sovrabbondanza che avrebbe provocato una
specie di corto circuito della nostra
attenzione la nostra attenzione è un
bene limitato di fronte al bombardamento
di informazioni che cosa succede
lo paragonava la differenza e questo
questo momento questa transizione tra
due epoche la differenza tra la
conoscenza come la conoscevamo noi
quella della mia generazione
quando i nostri genitori compravano
l'enciclopedia treccani facevano le rate
per comprare le enciclopedie
l'enciclopedia stavano in un angolo
erano come un lago erano stati che si
attingeva informazione
oggi l'informazione è una cascata della
mia gara e noi ci siamo sotto è un
flusso continuo e che cosa si vede si
sente quando si è sotto una cascata che
attenzione diamo alle informazioni che
ci passano davanti
e allora ecco che nell'anno 14 del xxi
secolo nell'età di twitter e facebook
lentini nell'età dei mille e schermi dei
mille devices iphone ipad televisione
cinema
c'era una volta distinzione tra piccolo
schermo grande schermo oggi abbiamo
milioni di schermi che ci circondano e
allora si è creata una reazione e la
reazione quale è quella che ci porta qui
oggi è una reazione alla velocità a
superficiale chiedendo tempo riflessione
it ibox sono una di queste reazioni
importanti perché
segnalano il desiderio della gente non
tantissimi ma sempre di più di fermarsi
almeno 15 minuti 15 minuti a riflettere
ascoltare un'idea condividere un
pensiero e quindi come le the top
i documentari creativi che si stanno ci
stanno fiorendo in questo momento al
crocevia tra tecnologia social media e
e analisi della complessità del mondo
che ci circonda
sono su un segnale di un bisogno di
fermarsi e di scardinare questa
illusione che con internet noi adesso
abbiamo più informazioni di quante ne
abbiamo mai avuta prima
non è così e un'illusione in realtà
molto spesso siamo più confusi di quanto
lo siamo mai stati prima
e allora ecco che queste forme di nuova
espressione di pensiero di conoscenza di
cultura come le tetto che come nuovi
documentari ci possono aiutare a fermare
il senso di una cosa a cercare di
pensare e capire
tra le tante buone notizie che la
tecnologia ci porta c'è questa di questo
dato che per la prima volta l'accesso
alla conoscenza e senza distinzione di
classe senza distinzioni di gruppo
sociale senza distinzione di censo
questi sono dei dati gli ultimi di
maurice che dimostrano che fino ai 45
anni adesso praticamente tutti sono su
internet e hanno accesso a queste nuove
tecnologie però che cosa ne fanno
harvard ha messo on line tutti i suoi
corsi universitari
ma quanti ragazzi di quelli che stanno
su internet si sono iscritti ai corsi
universitari tra avere accesso internet
e andare su facebook o
scambiarsi foto di gatti e andare sul
sito di harvard ce ne corre
e allora ecco che secondo me la mia
generazione la generazione che
che mi hanno preceduto si trovano in una
posizione storica di grande
responsabilità perché noi siamo una
cerniera siamo un ponte e quindi abbiamo
abbiamo il bisogno di chiederci ma che
strumenti lasciamo a chi viene dopo di
noi c'è il famoso detto che dice che noi
non ereditiamo il mondo dei nostri
genitori me lo prendiamo in prestito dai
nostri figli e gli strumenti di
conoscenza lasciamo i nostri figli in
questo momento io ci penso quando guardo
le mie figlie che hanno 11 e 9 anni e
sono già digital natives sono bambini
digitali quindi pensano in modo non
lineare stanno su internet sul telefono
cercano di fare i compiti rispondendo
agli amichetti
guarda che non è possibile non puoi fare
i complimenti a piedi è assolutamente
possibile già funziona in un modo
completamente diverso e pensano di
essere informati però in realtà quali
sono gli strumenti che loro hanno e
quelle secondo me la riflessione su
su questi nuovi strumenti di conoscenza
i documentari creativi e anche
importante perché quello che noi abbiamo
visto congar fendi da com è che in
qualche modo siamo riusciti a comunicare
con dei linguaggi che non erano per i
tradizionali con tantissimi ragazzi e
giovani che invece non riuscivano a
connettersi con gli strumenti di
informazione tradizionali e qual è l
evidenza di quello che dico ci sono dei
the film bellissimi per esempio inside
job premio oscar nel 2010 e cinco stato
20 trilioni di dollari che ci racconta
come è funzionata come quelle veramente
stata la crisi finanziaria è un film che
andrebbe visto da tutti perché i 90
minuti
capisci quello che molte persone non
capiscono avendo letto i giornali per
quattro anni su che cosa è successo
veramente sulla crisi finanziaria è un
caso famosi secolo della inconvenience
rudy al gore che ha cambiato idea al 98
per cento delle persone che lo guardano
su che cosa è il cambiamento climatico è
un caso importantissima è quello di the
actor killing un ultimo documentario che
ha riaperto la storia dimenticata del
genocidio in indonesia mettendo in scena
di nuovo il genocidio nella nelle parole
degli assassini
un film molto controverso ma molto
importante
e la cosa possiamo fare noi per
partecipare a questa rivoluzione
possiamo smette di pensare che siamo un
audience e siamo passivi e possiamo
diventare
parte di questo processo e in che modo
il film che stiamo facendo adesso per
esempio sarà cloud sost
chiediamo alla gente di diventare
produttori con noi e possono partecipare
in qualsiasi modo possibile a seconda di
quanto pagano avranno il nome mentito di
coda come produttore produttore
esecutivo
stiamo cercando di coinvolgere la gente
a partecipare a questi film perché se
questi film sono indipendenti e possono
diventare un metodo di conoscenza hanno
bisogno il pubblico faccia la sua parte
non solo come produttore ma anche come
distributore quello che sta succedendo
infatti che la consumazione di film si
sposta sempre di più online
quindi c'è un movimento molto molto
netto tra il modo di come film prima di
adesso e questo film per esempio che è
già stato girato su
sulla rivoluzione di times square è
stato prodotto per la prima volta da un
distributore di documentario on line ed
è stato candidato all'oscar è stato
un evento incredibile perché significa
che un distributore di documentari
online ha intercettato una domanda da
parte di chi compra i film online che
giustifica l'investimento in un film un
film molto importante che ci racconta la
vera storia di quello che è successo nel
nella piazza di times square
e questi sono altre cose che stanno
succedendo interessantissime sono web
interattivi sono dei documentari su
internet che permettono nello stesso
momento questo si chiama casa sderot e
permette di vedere nello stesso tempo la
vita in israele in palestina ed è
interattivo per cui guardandolo online
si può scegliere di andare da una parte
dall'alto e confrontare per la prima
volta le parole di tutte e due le
persone che si trovano parti diverse del
conflitto
insomma parlava parlava prima
relatore della nostra dipendenza da
internet da facebook c'è un'opportunità
ma c'è anche un rischio
sentiamo dipendenti dall'iphone
lo usiamo sempre più rapidamente
velocissimamente iphone smartphone che
si voglia
i ragazzi come 37 per cento ammettono di
usarlo anche nel bagno
stanno succedendo delle cose e possiamo
cambiarle possiamo riaccendere la luce
delle informazioni poi documentari o
possiamo invece scegliere di scambiarci
le foto di gatti che assomigliano a
putin
grazie